Du gaming !
du gam-ing! C'est parti aujourd'hui messieurs-dames nous nous retrouvons pour jouer à un jeu vidéo
ça fait très longtemps... Je crois que ça fait plusieurs mois qu'on a pas joué sur la chaîne
Alors, tout d'abord sachez que j'ai ouvert une nouvelle chaîne Youtube et j'en ai pas parler sur cette chaîne là j'en ai juste parlé sur
les réseaux sociaux qui s'appelle squeezie live sur laquelle je mets des best-of de mes lives il y en a actuellement déjà 8 et ça a
l'air vraiment de vous plaire alors si vous n'aviez pas entendu parler de la chaîne puisque je n'ai parlé que sur les réseaux sociaux et
ben foncez vous abonner regarder les best of et faites moi vos retours j'en sors environ deux par semaine voilà pour ceux  qui veulent du GAMING !
vous êtes servis. Les amis aujourd'hui on s'attaque à du lourd du très très lourd du très très dure Trap Adventure
qui a tout fraîchement fait le buzz sur les réseaux sociaux des amis écoutez et bien je n'ai qu'une parole écoutez moi bien regarder moi
bien dans les yeux
rire je suis hyper agressif… Aujourd'hui on va terminer le jeu auquel on joue !
et ça c'est pas arrivé depuis longtemps mec. C'est un peu comme Cats Mario, Unfair Mario vous vous souvenez à
Vous vous souvenez, à l'époque, on y avait joué et vous adorez voir les youtubers souffrir et moi j'adore
souffrir pour vous alors putain l'échange il est génial. Bon j'ai la flemme de vous expliquer en gros voilà on joue un petit bonhomme
on peut sauter ou s'accroupir
et aller à gauche et à droite c'est bon ? en haut à gauche on peut voir le nombre de vies que j'ai avant de
faire un game over et de recommencer le jeu du début et en attendant il y a sûrement des pièges cachés par ci par là comme ça
voilà comme ceux, comme des pics très original bravo ça fait plaisir se fait longtemps je m'étais pas fait souffrir devant un petit jeu hein.
Mec si je meurs là où y a pas de piège ça va être très tendu
C'est bon on y va deuxième niveau
Tsss,  ça me fatigue déjà mec mais je commence à connaître les mécaniques tu sais au bout de six ans de jeu rageant alors la ruse c'est
qu'il faut sauter dessus au bon moment quand il revient
ALLER
*Suprise* PUTAIN
Alors les pics qui viennent il faut les esquiver hop
*bruit chelou*c'est rigolo non en vrai je trouve ça drôle un peu
Et là c'est bon ?
*rire* C'est fatiguant !
Et c'est la première fois que ça me fait rire
Tellement c'est subtile et bien fait
QUOI MAIS MEC
ATTENDS-TENDS-TENDS
on va retrousser les manches tous ensemble et on va montrer à ce développeur de quoi on est capable
Et on va montrer à ce développeur  *craquement d'os*
De quoi on est capable
Alors y a quoi, maintenant y a quoi
AHHHH !!!
Aller "vamos" faut aller dans le trou
Voilà tiens on n'a pas besoin de trous nous
Quoi ??
bah alors quand je m'approche de l'extrémité droite
Il y a des pics qui viennent dire "bonjour"
alors peut-être qu'il faut aller à gauche et qu'on peut
retourner dans le niveau d'avant
sauf qu'en faite ça sera le niveau d'après
quelqu'un a compris ?
100% c'est ça ok
Alors regardez bien... hop on va chercher la boule on revient
HOOOOOOOOO ha dans le trou
ça fait trop de truc à analyser d'un coup mec
Tu te rends compte de tous les éléments qu'il faut prendre en compte
MAIS MEC LAISSE MOI PARLER
Ho j'ai l'impression de faire une vidéo comme en 2013
ça me fait très plaisir
La boule... Ho là c'est chaud
Elle est bien collée
HOOP
WHOUHHH !
ça vous avez manqué mes cris ?
ça t'avait manqué Nats?
*Mais je m'en bas les couilles de ta demande d'ami (?)*
Alors nouveau Level
Ha c'est comme le jeu où...
Oui ok je sais plus le nom mais
Où la boule elle vient, elle rebondit
et faut pas qu'elles touchent l'eau sinon t'as perdu
Faut envoyer une boule ?
Ho Ok je l'ai, je l'ai, je l'ai, je suis un tueur je l'ai, je l'ai
NON donc là en gros elle va vers le bas et quand je la retouche
attends j'ai rien compris
en fait je crois que dès qu'elle touche un mur elle change de sens
oui c'est ça regardez
là HOP elle m'a touché
donc elle était re-attirée vers le haut
C'est bon j'ai compris
Par le bas
Par le haut
JE COMPRENDS RIEN
Attends mais si je descends maintenant
HO MEC mais c'est bon en fait
faut juste que je descende elle fait sa life je suis trop con
oui je peux aller en bas il ya des trucs qui veulent me tuer là bas
Elle fait quoi la boule elle bouge plus
ELLE FAIT QUOI ELLE EST BLOQUEE !?
LA VIE EST INJUSTE
Alors je veux juste tester un truc
Oh c'était ça
il faut juste se coller au mur et envoyer plein de boules
Non il en manque un
Non attends je peux y aller
OUIIIIIII
HOOOOOO
Pardon, 1 2 3
4.5
Ah j'ai compris il faut se baser sur un deux trois soleil
c'est le même rythme 1 2 3 soleil
Bah là, tu fais 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 !
Personnes a compris absolument cette ref c'est pas grave
alors comment on fait ok faut que j'arrive
YES
ça ça descende là je passe là
ça descende là je passe là
Et il y a la ligne...
Putain
Attends mec si ça se trouve c'est pas là où j'allais
Je dois m'assurer que c'est pas ici
ET TIENS
Qu'est ce que tu vas faire !?
AHHH !
Pardon
*Musique au piano*
OH LES PICS !
Oh, les fils de putes quand tu crois que tout est enfin fini !
EH BAH NON
Hop
OOOHHH !
On n'a plus qu'une vie
j'aimerais au moins comprendre la mécanique de ce level
pour la prochaine fois
alors petit sous-marin
Petit game over
allez je veux ma soucoupe qui lâchent des bombes
alors faire gaffe aux bombes
Mais l'explosion elle est  hardcore
Ah mais je sais il faut se mettre au dessus du vide en fête
Donc du coup, il faut prendre ça
et juste se mettre là enfaite
Ah le bâtard
les PICS nous bloque donc je pense qu'il faut qu'on berne le pic comme Stéphane regardez
....
AH PUTAIN
Et on y est, oh oui ! OH OUIII !
oh non...
C'est beau aller à droite on mais qu'on va y arriver starfoulah, on y arrive
won han mec mecs dans mec s'te plaît quoi non mais je peux pas voir un game over de quoi ça me plairait trop à
ahah *rire forcé*
*pleurs*
*bruit de formule 1 qui passe*
Oh
Pardon excusez moi excusez moi c'est pour exprimer et maintenant
au yes sa a pété le mur faut que je calcul les bombes sa va raté?! Aller on lance les paris
je parie 10 euros que je rate si je rate pas je dois 10 euros x 10 millions
non je change de paris je donne 500 euros à une association
si je réussis je le fais vraiment tout de suite
Bravo connard
Oh!
attend quoi ah ok faut péter les murs ok faut se placer de manière à péter les murs ouais c'est ça
non je me suis foiré ! C'est pas grave allez deux vies, deux vies, on peut finir le jeu avec deux vies. Finalement qu'est-ce que c'est deux vies dans une vie hein?
il faut laisser tomber là il faut avancer ? la faut re-décaler et là c'est bon? Oh mec je suis trop chaud !
aller, on a deux vies on peut le faire !
OH AHHHH !
NON !!! L'enchaînement de meeeeerde !!!!!
Bon, en vrai, là je commence à avoir un petit skill a un peu tout comprendre du coup j'ai vraiment du plaisir à y jouer
allez c'est maintenant
OOOHHHH
mec je pense que l'on s'approche vraiment de la fin du jeu level 11 ont a le droit de regarder donc là il faut tout calculer
c'est ça et je parie que ça glisse en plus la surface
*bruit de semelle qui glisse*
ah oui
Fils de pute
on aura pratiqué c'est pas grave on a pratiqué on va se rassurer en disant que on a pratiqué
je n'arriverais jamais à temps je crois que en fait le dernier cube se...
ok d'accord dès que je touchais un cube en glace le dernier que vous voyez à droite diminue en taille donc a mon avis il y'a un cube
que je peux éviter mais lequel
Eh bien on saura peut- être plus tard
*musique*
*BIP*
Les amis je suis arrivé au niveau où il ya les petits éclairs de merde. Vous vous rendez pas compte à quel point c'est du jeu le
plus dur auquel j'ai jamais joué mais vraiment pour de vrai, mais je pense qu'on doit être à la moitié la putain. Allez c'est maintenant
on y va.
*musique de motivation*
Mec je l'ai passé
j'ai envie de pleurer. Alors ça glisse faut faire quoi ? On se baisse, on se baisse , on se baisse on se bai...merde
Ahh (désespoir)
Laisse moi au moins voir si je suis proche de la fin ou pas
c'est ça qu'il faut savoir aujourd'hui mais je pense je suis aux deux tiers un vrai gros le jeu est gratuit le mec se serait pas fait chier
à ce point. Ma première réussite 12 minutes 11
attend ça c'est qu'à une minute dix de son putain ?Non mais il le fait en boucle. Moi j'en suis là voilà
QUOI?? ça c'est qu'une minute 50 sur douze minutes 10 ça veut dire que je suis qu'à un sixième du jeux
est-ce qu'il faut rire, pleurer? Faut faire quoi là dans cette situation? Je croyais que j'étais un mec stylé d'en être arrivé la,  je croyais avoir fait mieux
que tous les autres youtubers
En fait je suis comme euuuuuux *pleurs* Jsuis une grosse merde
Les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo l'échec  qui est extrêmement dur à avaler mais mec ca fait deux heures et demi que je
suis dessus mais je suis qu'à un quart! bon les amis je vous parle sérieusement si vous voulez un deuxième épisode n'hésitez pas aimer la
vidéo et à me dire en commentaire que je sache parce que là si je tourne un deuxième épisode ça veut dire que je dois tourner
7 heure parce qu'à chaque fois qu'on va perdre toutes nos vies moi je vais devoir tout me retaper ça ce sera que cuté
au montage. Mais ça va être une journée
entière à jouer à ce jeu je suis prêt à le faire mais il faut que ça vaille le coup parce que mec déjà là
psychologiquement je suis dans un état ! j'en peux plus!
alors dites moi et on se trouve bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo, je m'en vais sauter du cinquième étage, au revoir!
AAAAAH * Crie*